l'autre grand titre de l'actualité c'est
la disparition de marlène dietrich la
star nous a quittés aujourd'hui elle
avait 90 ans dans l'aisne dietrich était
à la fois une actrice de talent et une
chanteuse à la voix légendaire tout le
monde se souvient de lili marlène
qu'elle chantait sur le front pour les
troupes américaines
c'était en 1939 marlène dietrich c'était
aussi une femme fatale à l'érotisme
troublant marie hélène bonin
m
l'inoubliable ange bleu maria magdalena
phone loches marlene dietrich
elle a tourné une trentaine de films
avec les plus grands metteurs en scène
raoul walsh hitchcock lubitsch orson
welles ou encore rené clair mais c'est
josef von sternberg qui la propulse au
firmament de sa gloire en 1930 avec
l'ange bleu et l'impératrice rouge en
1934 elle était née à berlin entre 1900
et 1904 la date de sa naissance n'a
jamais été connu avec certitude
devant la montée du nazisme et s'exile
aux états unis en 1938 ribbentrop l'a
pris à la demande dit l'air de revenir
en allemagne
elle refuse et choisi le camp des
alliers sillonne le monde combat le
nazisme à la libération elle reçoit la
légion d'honneur pour services rendus à
la france mais elle continue à tourner
régulièrement
win shine et anne favoriserait le mois
mais lourd mais marlène dietrich la star
à la voix rauque pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale les soldats allemands
fredonne lili marlène pendant qu'elle
faisait des tournées dans l'autre camp
pour soutenir le moral des soldats
américains
aurier les les
donc les 1976 l'actrice vivait recluse
dans son appartement parisien de
l'avenue montaigne à deux pas des champs
elysées en 79 elle avait publié ses
mémoires
elle avait su entourer sa vie privée de
mystère et dell annonce de sa mort cet
après midi les admirateurs de l'actrice
arrivait devant son domicile
marlène était quand même quoi qu'il
arrive la plus fan des femmes va je veux
dire c'est et tout et tout était
possible fait par mme harel
marlène dietrich le dernier grand mythe
du cinéma disparaît à la veille de
l'ouverture officielle du festival de
cannes
la fiche de ce 45e festival c'est elle
la star fascinante où professeurs de sa
gloire